That Navy SEAL you see
before you is holding
a gun made by Biofire.
Its very, very big claim
is that it's the first company
to make a smart gun that actually works.
That's right.
James Bond-style
fingerprint and facial recognition.
The gun only fires
if the right person is holding it.
It knows somebody is holding onto it.
But no matter how much he pulls
the trigger, nothing's going to happen.
The person who started
Biofire is Kai Kloepfer.
He's all of 25 years old and has been working on making this gun
for ten years, a project he started shortly after the Aurora theater shooting.
At the time, it's
like the worst mass shooting in history.
And it happened right just down the road
here from where I grew up.
I was fortunate enough to not have
to think about gun violence or gun deaths
and that was really
my first sort of encounter
with the topic, right?
I was just starting to
grow up, just starting to think
about these kind
of topics as a 15 year old
and really start to think about:
how could we do something about this?
I started thinking about this concept
of a smart gun.
By no means am I the first person to think
about this, obviously,
and it's been science fiction forever, but
nobody had ever really built a working
smart gun.
Okay, so you're 15. Yeah.
And instead of doing some policy
that you're kind of you're inspired.
Yeah. I was never a policy person, right?
I've been forced to become a little bit
more of one, you know, over the last
ten years. But no I was an engineer.
I was a socially awkward nerd.
A bona fide nerd who clinched his nerd bona fides by getting
an award at the very prestigious Intel International Science and Engineering Fair.
So, okay, so for people who don't know,
I mean, this is like no joke.
It's like, yes, thousands of the world's
smartest kids
Top. The year I went, it was the top 1500
out of over 8 million people.
8 million people. Right.
Yeah. Like this is the top of the top.
It’s as high as it gets
I think for the science fair world.
At the time
I was mostly an electrical engineer
and I could sort of fake my way
through some mechanical engineering.
So built a pretty good electrical system and a
really s***** mechanical system
Sort of slapped them together
into this kind of gun-shaped object,
not an actual firearm in any way,
I wasn't allowed to bring a gun
to the science fair, quite obviously.
I was very surprised by all this.
You know, I'd done a lot of science
fair projects before.
Three quarters of the time people didn't
believe that I'd actually built them.
They thought my parents had did them.
I mean this in the nicest way
possible, Dad, I'm sorry, but
my dad needs help like turning his iPad on.
After ten years of toil, Kai
is understandably proud
that his business finally has a product
to sell.
After you. Today we've got one of our Mark
Mark II prototypes, production
units of the smart gun.
So as soon as I start to interact with it,
I'm going to see those white lights.
The white lights
basically mean that it's active.
It sees that somebody has picked it up,
but it hasn't recognized the user yet.
So it's still locked.
To set up the gun, you register
your face and fingerprints on this device
in less than a minute where you can also
add and delete other users.
If you're not registered, Nothing.
Fingerprints are very well optimized,
very commercially mature.
You don't need a lot of processing power
to run them appropriately.
Facial recognition
is a cutting edge biometric,
which means it requires
orders of magnitude more processing power.
So where previously we were able
to just use like little microcontrollers
and things like that to do fingerprints,
we've had to basically build
an entire computer hardened for the system
that works inside of a gun
to be able to run facial recognition
at the speeds that our customers demand.
I’ve shot
guns before,
but am far from a gun enthusiast.
In many ways.
I'm Biofire’s target audience.
A dad who wants to keep his family safe,
but who also thinks having a gun at home
probably ends up more dangerous than good.
Still, old gun or new, I
needed a few pointers.
Yeah, I would try to lean forward like,
just like me.
Like, lean into it a little bit.
There you go.
Okay.
And again,
target's, like, less than ten feet away,
so you don't need to worry
too much about aiming.
Let’s not point that out.
Sorry- the target is like 100
plus yards away.
Ashlee is about to do a marksman level
sort of shot here.
Am I cool to try it?
There you go.
It still had more kick than I thought
I was going to.
It’s all good.
It kicks, and from my experience,
it works.
The question is, will it sell?
Several companies have tried
and failed to make a smart gun
because it's really hard to do.
And not just because you're mixing
sensitive electronics
with regular explosions.
Okay, so you've chosen to do a startup
doing this incredibly hard technology
and then to wade into like a Second
Amendment sort of issue.
Right. So this is like nightmare
keeps it interesting
that, as Kai has a talent for doing,
is putting the controversy mildly.
Pro-gun folks hate these things because
they fear that one day the government
will use the existence of a working smart
gun to ban the dumb ones,
even flirting with smart guns leads
to death threats and financial risks.
One of the reasons Biofire’s investors
prefer to stay anonymous.
And plenty of anti-gun folks don't
like them because, you know, they're guns.
For his part, Kai is not interested in
mandating or even advertising his product.
Biofire, he says, is just here to provide
choices and maybe save lives.
The key thing that we are trying to solve,
which I think we could completely solve,
is children and teenagers
gaining access to firearms.
Firearms are now the leading
cause of death for children.
and teenagers in America.
They surpassed motor vehicle accidents
for the first time in 2020.
I've never talked to a gun owner
who wanted their kid to find their gun.
And so we think that by building
technology that, you know, basically
works with the gun owner to enforce
what they're already looking to do
allows us to really actually address
that portion of the
of the challenge
of basically gun deaths in America.
The final version of Biofire’s gun
arrived in April with this funky sci-fi
look.
It's definitely more Halo, than Red Dead
Redemption.
But how well it will sell
is anyone's guess.
We want it to look modern and futuristic
and a little different
than everything else
that's on the market, obviously.
When I saw that one, it does
have a little sci-fi thing going on.
And again,
we don't want to look too normal,
but we don't want it to look like only,
you know, it's looking like a sci-fi nerd.
Like the Cyber Truck or something.
Yeah exactly.
I was trying to not say that.